Tik Tok live puts you into [__]
people's feeds while you're on so on
Instagram you go on it pings all your
users and a certain percentage comes
over and then it declines for me it's
like 2,000 come on right away and then 5
minutes later from Yapp and I look up in
the corner it's 800 it declines cuz my
crew gets pinged they check it out
they're like I don't give a [__] with
Gary's doing the route Tik Tok you go on
it pings p and you're that's right you
start you look over there's 600 and then
you look an hour later you weren't even
doing anything proper and there's 4,000
people there and here's the big thing
I'm saying to you three and obviously
I'm saying it for everyone at home
attention is the number one
asset hey everybody welcome to another
episode of podcast with friends I've got
three phenomenal friends in the building
most of all I want to give a huge shout
out to everybody on Twitch that is
watching this podcast live right now I
will be glancing over and trying to
incorporate you into the show if uh
you're listening at home on the
treadmill or a couple days later
whenever we post this make sure you go
to Twitter twitch.tv/ garve subscribe up
big shout out to everybody who's about
to give uh some uh uh subscribes uh gift
subs and all that and so I'm excited to
be here we're going to go around the
horn and say hello first of all and so
why don't all three of you find
gentlemen take two three minutes on not
only who you are but why don't you tell
the Vayner Nation that's tuned in and
obviously everybody listening at home a
little bit about who you are so let's
let's start with you Bree hello I'm
Kevin spe I'm known on the internet as
uh Grill guy
um I do no grilling um but yeah that's
what I do uh originally a I was an
educator I actually know Brandon from a
past work experience I love that um he
John Dey High School P fail baby it's
the only way I got through High School
pass fail pass fail so I was a I was a a
basketball coach and teacher at John
Dewey High School in Brooklyn love um he
don't graciously donated a scoreboard to
our team and um and was a graduation
speaker so we got to chop it up few a
very East Coast show I'm excited about
this jersey Brooklyn Queens speaking of
Queens I was a coach at York College in
Queens for a little bit yeah that's near
and me that's right down the block
that's Jamaica Jamaica right near me
yeah yeah and then uh started teaching
or started coaching in New Jersey and
moved out to New Jersey had a son and
during paternity leave just started what
part of yours um I'm in Scotch Plains oh
I know super well my dad's first liquor
store was in Clark New Jersey yes
Catholic right down the street
okay yeah so we're all we all know the
same same spots this a very Jersey dude
show so you better you New York TR State
you better really settle the [__] in
everyone it's about to it's about to
happen so okay so it you know during the
paternity leave you're like [__] it let
me make videos yeah uh kind of actually
I had a friend who works at a a media
company called doing things media and
they said hey we have this idea for a
millennial dad grilling show like would
you want to do it I said sure I'll give
it a shot and I was really bad at it
yeah I was really really bad at it I but
you know I was unet to leave I said give
me you know let me try it I started
making skits you know 30 second skits
minute skits with my phone and like a
$15 tripod which I still use and slowly
but surely over time it I it hit yeah
there wasn't like a one day that like
really yeah it just it took time and and
now I do it full-time I'm I'm no longer
teaching no longer coaching I miss a l
what's the handle that everyone could
find you on uh Grill guy at Grill guy at
Grill guy under on Tik Tok grow guy uh
gr guy that hurts you right that
underscore [__] with you yeah messes
with me a little bit Yeah so I don't
know who I got to pay but eventually
bang me for let me know good seg for me
why don't you tell the uh about this is
an OG Legend everyone uh play pay your
[__] respects in the chat than sir
well I appreciate it good to see again
I'm still grinding and you know I that's
all you know I still wake up broke still
working yeah still working love the work
if somebody comes to my office again ask
me what when the [__] I'm retire and I'm
going to be really pissed cuz you're
going to die your desk disrespectful I'm
like I'll retire when I'm are are you
going to die at your desk or are you
going to retire want to get home first
before yeah I'm I I worry about the
dying at the desk uh that would be
troubl that's the slang term from do you
think you'll work no I get it I'm going
to work yeah I'm going to the end yeah
I'm going to work I'm going to negotiate
my barrial yeah I'm negotiating
everything and I'm already working with
the man upstairs trying to get that
squared away because there's a lot of
work to be done I think the first thing
is like Gary first of all you know
thanks for having me and and you I'm not
at Steiner anymore which is so crazy and
we were just having
dinner and I remember you saying brand
your brand your name it's it's bigger
than any of it don't worry about it like
whatever way it goes don't forget you
got your name you're never going to lose
it and it's hard to be not at Steiner
but I so I love that the Steiner thing
still living on but I came up with
something better which I remember I
didn't I was telling you about and I put
it in a play and collectible
exchange.com is like this Marketplace I
realized there was a lot of older people
like me that have a shitload of stuff
and they know what to do with it so now
we have like 150,000 items on there I
don't think I W 35 at Steiner and I
bought star stock you're a fan of star
stock yep I got to get in the trading
card game so I'm and what's great about
the trading card is like I'm a crazy
collector obviously have a lot of issues
but I wasn't like a training card like
Guru I'm a collectible deep into it and
now like I'm learning from all these
kids that are coming at me like Star
stock should be this star stock should
be that I'm in a position though to make
it into that I love it so I think you
can never not listen to your customers
and that's kind of where I'm at I'm
loving the collectible business I'm
loving that there's so many young kids
in this game and I love when I hear from
them and I love the diversity of the
product I'm able to carry now so one
more thing is you're not going to
believe this [__] but this weekend I'm
opening up my first show with eBay live
let's go doing a Regular Show three
times a week I went to them I wanted to
be like an educator obviously I'm always
going to be selling some [__] but I'm
going to be an educator I want to tell
people about the ins and out to this
business what to look out for y what do
you get graded what you don't get graded
what to get authenticated there's a lot
of people that just don't know and they
have a lot of stuff they're embarrassed
so they give me this opportunity putting
a lot of money behind it good for you
very grateful for eBay to give me this
opportunity EB I shout out to eBay two
iconic people coming together Brandon
Steiner Steiner Sports was iconic in you
know and especially that Yankee run was
like so Legend you you'd be like I'm
like I got to get the dirt from Yankee
you were selling everything just as a
great got that as a you know I gave him
a pen by the way this is like my you got
to have balls pen for my book and it has
the actual dirt from the last game
Yankee Stadium you can have it it's all
yours so yes I'll give you another one I
I'll give you
one so anyway Marano at the last game
he's carrying out this dirt he gave me
half of it and I filled that up with
that so you got a little Mar special of
the closer I'm sending you some [__]
I'll what you got first Z will
Entertainer um artist now um I'm from
Queensbridge New York
um you know I'm 22 years old I started
this entertainment comedy stuff back
during Co um when it was nothing to do
I'm just in the house making videos um
had the first video go viral hit a
million views and from then on I'm just
doing you addicted right I was addicted
it's like cuz I'm in the house I don't
got nothing to do I'm in a crib I'm
making videos everybody's loving it it's
getting millions of views um and then
you know I end up getting a 2 million 3
million now I've aass like 12 million
follows overall um and now you know
right now we getting into the music
stuff I got a song called chaa out it's
going viral they love it on Tik Tok it's
crazy you don't like the Dance come on
do the I got to teach you to dance too
before we get out of here I'm going to
had another song called Freaky would
blew up so right now I'm just getting
into my music stuff and and and keeping
the comedy alive and you know I'm
getting a lot of comparisons like Will
Smith on on the entertainment side and
on the rap side they calling me like
Eminem and you know I'm just having fun
with it I'm just I'm just living in the
did you say here you're a mix between
Will Smith and M that's a crazy mixture
right I get it I'm telling you but like
when you hear the freestyles and you
hear me rapping and then you know as as
the podcast goes on you get the see more
my personality I'm just I'm A vibe I
just be chilling and Hooper I think I
hoop too Gary I be dunking on him I'm
trying to tell you I seey as [__] bro
hey I see it we need we need my house to
play man this guy does it prop my
brother plays that at the full court we
can do that indoors I'd be stunned if
you didn't have hops you look lanky lank
[__] yeah you look I'm hoping let's go
boys let's go vulnerable from the top
what's the thing that you're most
struggling with real talk no [__]
right now we're all in very different
life cycles what you know grills what
what is like what is like the thing if I
said if we were like best friends and
like we had dinner tonight and we hadn't
caught up in a 100 days and I started
with cuz this look there's a lot of
people watching right now and like a lot
of them would like to have the things
that have happened to the four of us
happen and you know they'll only see the
it went viral he got it was so easy he
just made a couple videos or right or
you know like like well they they did it
for a long time that seems too hard I
don't want to take 10 years 20 years to
build we grew up in a world that didn't
exist like these guys were able to have
quick moments and then they had to build
something for us it was the reverse we
had to build something for a long time
and then you got your moment so the
world's moving there's a lot going on
like in a real way I I feel like this
podcast with friends is like people
really having a real conversation
especially with like making new
acquaintances strangers so if I said to
you like what's the thing that you're
most struggling with right now what is
it uh genuinely it's balancing having a
second kid yeah I have uh I mean blessed
two healthy kids the
best out of all the things I've done in
my life and I've done some really cool
things and had some difficult times
without question being a father is the
best thing I've ever experienced I think
it's Peak life I don't think there's
anything better than being a father it's
also difficult it also takes um it takes
tolls on other areas of life and so
having this having zero to one you're
ready for it you're like oh we're having
a baby cool that's all you're worried
about is the one baby then that baby is
a toddler yes and then that has its own
challenges and then you're trying to
bring in a second life so it's like
little K strugg problems big kids big
problems yeah and I spend a lot of time
with the ogs and they've got 40-year-old
kids
and you never stop being a parent yeah
when your 59y old child has a problem
and you're 83 it's [__] you up
because they're still your [__] child
yeah and so you know and so is it it's a
t you're also in a tricky spot yeah you
have more opportunity than you've ever
had professionally mhm you're a young
man youngish I'm 36 you're a young man
thank these [__] kids you're a young
man yeah you've got nothing but
opportunity to build in front of you you
you as a human have those feelings but
you've got these other things Brewing
that are the most important things in
life how do you make it all go and also
feel at the same time so lucky that I'm
able to say that my the thing I'm
worried about right now is balancing two
kids you know I yeah you're grateful
yeah I'm super grateful I mean I'm a
cancer survivor so that that gives me
perspective yeah that's do yeah it was
testicular though so rip to the left one
y um but still got the right one um the
right 's the one you need that's the
only one I need it got me the kids uh
but yeah so definitely feel grateful
that that's the biggest thing going on
in my life but it's it's still your
thing yeah it's my thing everybody's got
their thing yeah you know like this is
why I always tell people do not envy
people that you think have it so great
LeBron and Jay-Z right now are worried
about something yeah and sometimes it's
something they're worried about that's
way more challenging than what you're
dealing with they may have Fame and
Fortune but they might have heard
someone that they love the most in the
world was diagnosed with not something
they were able to win like you were
something they can't win and it's a WAP
and I promise you they're more upset
today than you are because you're
worried about maybe not having money to
get some stuff but if you have like
literally like people not leaning into
Simplicity is is unfortunate yeah cuz
when you lean into Simplicity you're
good mhm yeah so so you're actually in a
great spot you're just trying to find
balance right now I'm in a great spot
I'm trying to find balance balancing you
know uh your relationship with your wife
also with like having new kids you know
try not to beat each other's neck too
many times so I'm lucky that I
have ites you know there's new dynamics
that weren't there before yeah it yes
and it's it's a beautiful thing to be
able to experience something new yeah so
I'm grateful for it Brandon you know
what's interesting it's like my wife has
done such a great job with our kids like
one of my biggest struggles is our kids
don't need us of course oh man like it's
unbelievable like you know one minute
one minute you can't breathe you can't
get them out of your bed you can't you
know you're smothered with them and the
next thing you know is like you're
begging you you got to go to these
luxurious vacation just to get them for
a week to hang out with them and it's
it's trouble some more for my wife than
me like I I I tell my wife you want to
help the kids stop helping them they
don't want your help what kid really
wants help from their parents they want
to do it on their own and that's exactly
how we raised our kids and that's
exactly how they're doing it and
sometimes it's hurtful you know when you
don't hear from your kid now or they're
doing so well on their own emptiness
[__] is tough it's tough man I remember
when my younger brother AJ who's years
younger than me like went to away to
college and I wasn't expecting this cuz
I was a young I was I was he was 18 I
was 29 this wasn't on my radar I just
started realizing my mom was and my mom
is the happiest most optimistic and AJ
went to school and I was like my mom was
weird and I was like what's going on and
I was like oh that's when I learned what
empty nest like she loved being a mom so
much it was her Destiny she is the
greatest of all time at it she was sad
as [__] that year yeah like that was
what she loved doing for the last 30
years and that that's like Parenthood in
a nutshell isn't it it's like what what
I would say to the young ones out there
and that is if I was going to throw
something out there said listen I know I
know parents are paying in the ass but I
apologize any best just said where did
Gary get that hat I've got crazy hats
coming from V friends this is ambitious
Angel hat I love it oh that's cool what
material is that uh where you get that
hat nice it honestly Brandon it's so
hard to get
is it you should be wearing it you
should be that no I really figured it
out I'm making so few of them it grab
that's not right man no this is very
good you got said I'm so excited about
this Brandon I finally made a cool
product cuz I've made product but I
finally finally actually did it like
actually so anyway like I'm going to I'm
going to slowly but surely trickle these
like tough I'm so happy right now that's
cool anyway go ahead you got flavor I
was going to say to S out there to the
young kids is like look parents are
paying in the ass but they ain't always
going to be around like you know you got
to sacrifice and you know something you
give your let your kid let your parents
help you a little bit it gives them the
joy and you don't have to be so proud
sometimes to take their help and advice
I think the other thing that's like
Troublesome for me is I've had a great
epic run so really in that little break
that I had like you sometimes you don't
realize what you've done what you've had
you're just so busy grinding you ever
think you going to have like a hit I was
around your agency today I like I wonder
if Gary was thinking he was going to
have like agency here in Amsterdam
London like it's outrageous I did I I
feel the same way but like now it
happened though it's to your point back
to your point brother I did but I'm
still grateful as [__] that it happened
as confident as by the way I think I'm
going to buy the New York Jets forget
about this [__] like I'm going to
pull it off they need you I'm very aware
but when it happens to your point
brother even though I truly believe it's
sitting here right now I will pinch the
[__] get out of myself that day I will
cry I will God willing cuz I think it's
going to take me some time God willing
my parents will be around like but like
it's like if not you then who you're
allowed to have conviction and
confidence and yet still have ridiculous
humility and gratitude that's where
people get confused you can have these
polar opposite energies sure I have
conviction and confidence and bravado
but that doesn't mean that I also don't
I also realize I don't mean [__] [__] me
if I disappear tomorrow I'll get a
little love on social media for a half a
day people say a little something and
then the world has to move on and that
and so you can have conviction but if
you don't match it with humility and I
get it brother you are absolute
entrepreneurial especially East Coast
Legend oh God it just doesn't stop I was
telling I was telling uh guys outside
like I wake up in the morning and the
bathroom is the last thing I'm thinking
of going I wake up in the middle of the
night I'm not going to the bathroom I'm
trying to write all the [__] that's
going on this brain down because there's
so many things you can do and I I try to
remind myself and especially now with
not being with a big company with all
the bosses I'm on a highway Gary with no
red
lights the only speed limit is the one I
put on myself just to give everybody
some listen as they listening it's crazy
Brandon obviously built this iconic
company he sold it he's out of multiple
but what he's talking about is when you
have when you're in a corporation you're
going slow as [__] and then when you let
an entrepreneur loose now he's going
fast again and like by the way it's by
the way the reason this agency got so
big and we have 2,000 people globally
now it's big big but the reason we're
winning is I fight to not be a
corporation even though we are because
we have 2,000 people we're just a little
less than everyone else and it's like
sports if you're just a little faster
that [__] plays out on that Court just a
little faster John Mor's just a little
faster than everybody right it's like
not a lot more yeah just that inch it's
like right let's talk basketball that's
a common
it's scary how just a little more than
everybody else and it's a completely
different game I always tell people when
you're when you're thinking I'm going to
outthink you when you're working I'm
going to outwork you and when you're
sleeping I'll outthink you and outwork
you like I wouldn't want to compete with
me CU you're you're you're shooting for
second place but what's nice is that
when you don't realize when you're in
some of these big companies sometimes is
just a million meetings a million memos
a million and it does slow you down to
drive you crazy and now uh I've been you
know it's funny at
65 I like somebody let me out5 so I'm
enjoying that freedom but on the flip
side from a problematic standpoint you
know balancing that realizing that you
can't do all that you can't kiss all the
girls so to speak like and they picking
my favorite project to work with my
favorite people so I'm able to
prioritize but that's it's tough because
all these opportunes come at you but
it's exciting and you know something um
for anybody who's out there's a little
bit older [__] do not let anybody
dictate when you're dreaming and when
you have to stop I love it yeah I love
it Z my biggest thing right now like I
would say balance like girl said having
my comedy and the music um because of
both is excelling for me so like it's
it's a lot going on on both sides but
when you get a song like I just dropped
and it's doing so well but the fans
still Z we want comedy we want comedy
and I love both but it's like I want to
work on what's going on right now like I
want to work on what's what's going so
you you right this minute want to in
deeper into the music but you feel the
pressure from the audience that you want
to deliver for them cuz that's how the
[__] you're even sitting here exactly so
you're trying to strategize of like [__]
like how do I make sure I don't alienate
by the way I went through this heavy the
way I popped off back in the day was in
2006 on YouTube I started making wine
videos and I did it for five years every
day and I was the wine guy right and
then I wanted to start talking about
being who I actually was which was
business and when I first started making
new videos that were not wine people
were not happy mhm stay in your lane
wine boy I'll never forget that quote
stay in your lane wine boy I've got much
worse that's what I but yeah this was
this was 10 years ago when people were
nicer it's like a good thing and a bad
thing cuz it's like why got oh you've
made so big of a name they know you for
something but then it's like when you
try to get out well this goes back to
this honestly yours is a lot more simple
than those two to me you have to die on
your sword in life the reason I'm always
happy is I have tons of [__] that don't
go well it's just that I always make
decisions that I want to make yeah the
only times in my life that I've been
really upset is when I listened against
my own intuition to something I
perceived was going to give me better
advice a parent a mentor someone I
looked up to randomly was just in a and
by the way I haven't done it a whole lot
I have to go way back in my bank because
somewhere pretty quickly real quickly in
my life I was like [__] this [__] if I'm
going to to lose I'm losing on my [__]
so for
you and even just the way you said it it
felt so obvious to me you need to go
hard on this music kick MH and if you
wake up in a year and your audience is
declining the music has not pump popped
off and you realized [__] I might have
[__] up I might have should have went
harder on Comedy or I should have done
both for a minute here's the good news
he's a baby you're a [__] you're still
in the [__] belly
22 never been called a baby yet if you
literally [__] up the next 24 months and
you guys are like damn we really like
[__] we we missed our moment no you
didn't mhm you didn't fully capitalize
on your moment yet you can change that
the next
day the next day yeah and so I think for
you if I may one man's point of view is
if you're if that [__] music is
pulling at you just go hard because
here's the problem if you don't in a
year and you're kind of in both but the
music didn't go to where it want or
you're kind of dreading the comedy and
you start resenting the comedy you're
not going to be in a good place cuz you
knew what you wanted to do but you
didn't all these [__] people living
for the algorithm bro yeah living for
the algorithm gra I experien something
similar where it's like I know if I do a
video that's like my son be like it's
going to do really well I don't find
that funny right so I have to balance
like doing stuff that I think is funny
that sometimes isn't going to perform as
well right but I know if I'm always
trying to do what like I know does well
I know what's sharable any anytime a dad
does like Dad Dad humor it does well but
like that's not always what I want to do
so I just try to balance it I have no
idea if it works or not I but for me
like I just don't want to look at
something you're going to win that game
there's so many people right now dude I
had this I bring this analogy up and it
it came through the other night I was I
read a lot of DMS which which is always
giving me a pulse of the feelings this
dude's like yo I really really really
want to talk about science but like I'm
a I'm a trainer and the only post that
do well is when I take my shirt off and
show my abs and like like like this is a
dude not like we we think about it from
the female perspective more often and
and I'm like bro you're unhappy post
your science video I understand it's not
going to get 30,000 likes and it's going
to get 600 but who gives a [__] that's
what you want and also eventually it
will if you it yeah like took the words
out of my mouth that was going to be my
segue and it's not sustainable when it's
not right for you yeah like it's it's a
losing game it's why I see so many
people losing they they milk the thing
that got them there for a year or two
after they didn't like it anymore and
the audience can smell it yeah if you're
not about that life you're not about the
streets don't [__] with a lot of rappers
because they know that the rapper is no
longer living that life yeah right right
and some stay there because they're
actually in it m the the the streets a
classic rap term but it's a macro
business term the streets don't [__]
with
people because they can smell it when it
becomes no longer authentic and if
you're still doing the [__] that always
works for you there's a million I've
sucked for the last year on YouTube I
just don't want to do the things that I
know will work better right now I'm busy
building my company by the way I'm doing
this because I need to get back into
Gary ve life the last year I've been
just sitting in this office for 15 hours
a day because I'm entrepreneur first
personalities cuz you've been kind of
quiet yeah in my view you like 100% I
feel like you've been kind of quiet I've
been quiet building a [__] foundation
for the next chapter and I'm like
incredibly happy about that me too man
I'm in the same boat I don't I don't
need all if I want credit I go to the
bank I I don't need the attention I love
it I'm flying right underneath the radar
doing my thing and I don't really give a
[__] what anybody else thinks about it
I'm already aware that there'll be 2031
I'll be hot again 2032 I'll be quiet
like I'm I'm not worried about it I'm
worried about doing good things there's
going to be es and flows listen I have a
15-year track record I promise you I
will be one of the [__] people that
pops off on whatever the next Tik Tok is
it's who I am and I'll be making videos
and because so many people didn't listen
to me on Tik Tok last time this next
time everyone's going to really go I
remember whatever you decide to do
people going to buy I wouldn't be in
social media the level I'm at without
you I remember I just I was completely
lost and and somebody office like you
got to [__] going I went to see some
speech I was like doing the I was doing
the opening you one of the Keynotes and
I was like who the [__] is this guy like
I'm like I guess I better start
listening like this shit's making sense
and then I got really into my Social cuz
you know again like all my friends were
like we're not doing Instagram we're not
doing Facebook we're not doing this I'm
like no I'm doing it back to my Pokemon
me SES so this is be friends my Pokemon
meets uh Sesame Street friend I want you
to open the pack and look at all four
cards and tell me which character most
resonates for you and then we'll go
around the horn this called
isn't this a rip ripping it I did this
like 3 weeks ago for the first time ever
in my life bet here you go here we go
resonates the most
yep he are
nice I'm going to go with I got mine all
right
G all right I'll go with selfless sloth
keeping with the parent uh Vibe okay so
I just traveled with to a toddler and a
baby it's great but I just I have to
tell you breaking down a stroller with
people behind you in a in like a
security line and nobody has patience
that you're a parent no one cares they
just need to go where they're going is
one of the most stressful things we got
through we got through it but I almost
bit someone head off okay um I'm going
with selfless sloth um cuz you're
leaning into that in your I'm leaning
into that I just my mind right now kid
right yeah for sure I think as a parent
your life immediately and it's again the
best thing ever becomes about other
people I think that's a really happy way
to live also I think about John Wooden
where it's like a life that's not lived
you know in service to others isn't a uh
a life worth living I don't know if
that's a quote I just made that up you
can write that down if you want cuz I
thought that was pretty good kind of
notes did any did anybody get did
anybody get a foil or did everybody get
just yellow cards I got yellow yell Yow
no foil cards right um so I'm going to
go with that yeah and I'm I'm with Sloth
I dig sloth so I'll stick with that
Brandon I don't know why but I'm liking
this brilliant Barracuda oh Barb the
Barb the bar I like it the fish just
happy ready to roll just moving right
along do you find yourself brilliant I
find myself at this point now looking
back going you know brand because I
always thought I was not that smart
having you know really struggle to read
struggle half illiterate the whole works
and now I'm like you know BR some pretty
smart [__] you did good for I give
myself a little more I got I got to
interrupt this program I'm really happy
I really like the relationship you have
with yourself you're I we point out a
lot I'm really happy that I feel like
you're really getting into a nice place
with yourself yeah I mean it's tough
when you're when you're fighting the
fight and grinding trying to get numbers
you don't always get your best self out
and that's what you got to avoid because
it's really all about the relationships
and about loving what you do and making
sure you love the people at home so I'm
very grateful my my wife keeps me
straight which is you know you know you
know my wife is hung in with a lot of my
[__] so I'm very grateful and thank
you for saying that I appreciate that I
feel it you're a Vibe you a Vibe man we
call it I'm young we you you a Vibe you
be chilling and you happy yeah thank you
not a lot of that not a lot of that V
chaa what you got I got curious crane
okay um that's me I'm always I'm always
I always want to learn something I
always want to learn something new I
feel like cuz all my life growing up I
always thought I knew everything that
was one thing my mother always said you
think you know it all cuz you had
conviction probably so right cuz that's
I want to break this down right cuz I
think it's a strength but to your point
being a knowt all and being if you don't
if you if you have conviction cuz you
knew yourself you knew you had it
without humility right so the reason
they're called be friends is some of
them work together so here is humble
hummingbird right so humble hummingbird
with conviction cockroach that's the
game you have conviction but if somebody
says some [__] you have that the
humility be like oh [__] I thought I
knew but I did it right conviction is
beautiful that's happened lot it
happened a lot but yeah definitely c as
can I'm always learn I always want to
know something new now um cuz I feel
like I don't know it all um and when I
feel like I don't well when I feel like
I do know it all something always goes
wrong for me um and I feel like you know
you got to go through that sometimes you
got to go through humility but you're
staying curious I'm I'm pretty I've been
doing pretty good doing pretty good were
you a good student in high school no I
was bad I was a bad kid I was a Class
Clown was anybody here a good student
cuz I wasn't a and now my teachers are
calling me oh my God my kids love you
they watch this from the top but I was
the worst pull it down from the
top the the sign the report grab it take
that down I love that take got a bunch
of passes look at this put in the middle
you want to see some [__] look at this
girls oh great oh my goodness look at
that break it down tell them give them
some give them some highlights this 9th
10th 11th and 12th grade I canot wait
cuz we prob got the same gr give them
some highlights girls you got a you got
a uh C in Ceramics which I'll give you
how you camic that right here Al one d
uh IPS I'm not sure what that is
irritable p b Center maybe you got a C
in that uh Speech you got a D hold on
how's that in speech giving speeches in
class I got a
dund most well-compensated public
speakers in the world currently and I
got a D in speech keep going uh let's
give you some some highlights you got uh
give them German one freshman year yeah
German you got a f you got a f in German
that wasth grade now on the bottom they
this is nth grade German this is 10th
grade German tell them what I got in
German one sophomore year F again okay
so just so everybody knows in Jersey in
Jersey bro you have to pass you have to
pass Spanish language you have to pass
language two years in New Jersey to
graduate high school same I come out the
gate freshman year I take German cuz I
was born in Russia and thought they
would be similar like an idiot ass I run
it back on some yo [__] that [__]
I'm coming back I'm getting a D in this
[__] I run it back F so then junior year
I have to go take Spanish one with
[__] eighth graders as a junior I get
Junior and Spanish one you got a D so
you passed you passed I got a D for one
reason big shout out Senora Kennedy the
only teacher in my life that saw me
called my mom and said I'm just going to
pass your son he doesn't even know what
Ola means what ola mean now hello I bet
what I get what I get in Spanish 2 my
senior year Spanish 2 senior year he
moved it up to a d which is d d two D's
D it's the same thing with me with
French my mother had to come up and beg
to teach you to pass pre I couldn't I
couldn't learn French check this class
rank what is my class rank class rank in
four years out of 254 students you are
243rd that's cold I wonder how many of
those that's I wonder yeah right I
wonder how many of how many the 242 what
are they doing what they doing exactly
yo ninth grade me if I was watching this
where' you go high school and I seen
that I'd be like oh yeah I it's hope I
got hope well this is why this by the
way I appreciate you saying that that's
literally what I'm you know who I'm
doing it for actually the
parents the kids don't get caught up in
this the kids know the reason we just
did that was for the parents that are
watching and the ones that are listening
at home I am remarkably happy [__] my
professional success my mom built me I
am gloriously happy as a human being I'm
very blessed mhm I'm clearly
professionally successful as well which
is secondary but still matters and this
was this thought that there's any
correlation and by the way then when
people are on the other side Gary that's
okay but you're an enigma no no I'm not
an enigma I'm aware that not everybody
reaches my level of happiness and
success but I know unlimited straight A
valedictorians that can't the career
students that they can't pull it off in
the real world I know tons of people all
four of us are bad at school all four of
us are chopping up right now like like
school is fine and it works and by the
way it matters for many people and
people learn different ways I just don't
think we realize that half the people
half don't learn the way this whole
system is built that's half the people I
would have uh conversations in like
parent teacher conference and I'd be
like your your kid is annoying in my
class but he's also really funny and
really personable so I'm I have to tell
you yes he's annoying and it's
disrupting the class but I said it nicer
than that but like also remind him like
that could be the strength that makes
him successful in whatever he does after
this doubt him him being personal and
coming to my class and smiling puts a
smile on my face and while he's at my
neck you know I'm at his neck you know
but hey the school you coached at my
mother was smart enough to realize she
put me in a pville high school yeah so I
got caught up in the learning not
worrying about the grades M and and end
going end up going to Syracuse which is
my friend still like going you're going
up the what's going on up there I'm like
I'm going up theuse never going back
which is my mother said look we're so
poor this what out ra have no grades no
money 760 on my boards combined I almost
got a zero on the English I go home I'm
crying like Mom like the guidance
Council tells me I shouldn't go to
college I should go to a trade school I
can't use the language it was so foul at
my mother went off she was going to go
up and beat the [__] out of the guidance
C mom you can't go up there she say I
want you to go get that book I want you
to find the most expensive School in New
York state that's what's going to give
us the most Aid I so how we going to
afford it we got no money nobody's going
to have the balls that has your grades
you look you've been working for 10
years you got to go up and make a sale
to Syracuse made a sale that's amazing
crazy that's mother though yeah moms I
always say moms are the most important
people in the world and they have the
biggest impact you it's actually very
common sensical you come out of them
facts I love what people like try to
argue like let me just make it very let
me end this discussion immediately you
we once inside of her you know what
insane that is like we don't think about
it cuz it's just so like I'm going to
say it nice and slow of course they are
yeah you were in there yeah you part of
the body this is like the most basic I
don't understand how people understand
it this is how you started let me tell
you where you all started in there from
the womb in your mama of course they're
the most important it's so funny when
people like like I'm like the music the
influence you think culture is more
important than the place You Came From
You Came the [__] out
of [__] are you talking about it's very
basic and true right basic is good this
is why I won this was all complicated
[__] by the way can you just tell
everybody the only A's I got in all four
of my I can you have an A on uh fiz
class a freshman year second year again
uh I'm not sure what Northwest world is
but you got to be in it is that history
history history was the one thing I
listen to did you have a cool teacher
that told fun stories or yeah we had
good teachers everywhere and Bad
Teachers it was just that I never knew
why I was good in History until I got
older I use history to tell me the
future smart yeah everything old is new
and so it's I didn't realize it was my
obsession with pattern recognition and
human behavior like why did there was
there a World War why did we go to vietn
the why so a in Jim freshman sophomore
junior year my only a was J year fette
again
and then you got two you got health and
fed yeah you was a gym Legend lie he was
I was you know what I was you know what
we called me a gym class hero I would go
to gym class like it was game seven of
the NBA Finals people were like warming
up I'm like I'm trying to kill people
like I it was the most important thing
for me in the world to Su like I don't
know how to not compete yeah like
they're like all right gym class we're
going to play I'm like I'm trying to
kill you yeah and that's when you could
play fun games like dodgeball I feel
like you can't even play that now cuz
like people get you know you can't hurt
someone you don't play dodgeball yeah I
know hit me in my head we play dodgeball
with the rubber balls that like bounce
off you not the like fo not the foone
ones yeah yeah we did the phone ones
what has been the thing this year where
where we by the way 8% of 2024 is over
jesz just to get the people that need a
little motivation it really [__] with
me yeah right didn't that hit you it's
[__] up when you say it that way right
damn I a lie right 8% is over already
February it's 8% January was the longest
year ever 8% but on that note oh my God
2024 is here now what has been the thing
you've seen in the last month that's
been interesting a person a trend an app
a brand anything in the first month of
the year and by the way if you want to
go back a couple months to the end of
last year in the last 100 days or so any
what's caught your attention give it
some thought anything that's caught your
attention a person a trend a
movement anything what has caught your
attention in in the game called pop
culture I already know one who's a
Creator I'll go with the Creator since
that's I guess that's what I am there's
this girl Veronica is cool big shout out
is just the funniest person I I I got on
her early like she had probably 60,000
followers on Tik Tok she has been
blowing up the past like two or three
months I'd say it is just one of the
funniest most creative and weird and
hilarious comedic skit uh people I've
seen just like you know when you watch
something and it's so funny to you that
you can't even laugh cuz your mouth is
open you're like what did I just watch
that's the kind of funny she is so
that's awesome yeah I've been I'm glad
I'm glad you gave her some flowers she's
crushing Brandon you know what's
interesting to me is I think people
dying to get out I just you know you go
to any event any
concert um you know I've done q&as I
haven't done it in a while because I
want to bringing experientials back
because that's my customers asking mhm I
I don't people going to come out I'm
like so I mean just did like a quick
Aaron Boon Q&A the manager of the
Yankees like sold out in like 15 minutes
people want to get out they want to get
back to meeting people getting around
people which is very promising and um I
think that trend is going to be strong I
mean you go to most concerts games
packed so people want to get out and if
you're out there you have the ability to
create situations for people to get out
it's good and you how you people go back
to work it's such a that's another issue
I've been in the office every day with
my staff but there's the hybrid thing
I'm a fan of it you know maybe you're
going to work 3 four days at least but I
think you're doing a disservice to
yourself I I realize some people can
work great from home but I think getting
in the office is healthy and and you
shouldn't avoid it yeah being in your
home by yourself 247 is just like it's
got some things I I agree with you the
real life stuff is very obvious to me as
well the real life experiential real
life events people are it's happening
the most important for the most thing
I've seen is is is kind of wild to me is
Snapchat okay and I don't think yall
know Snapchat now is different from than
the when it was like now you know people
got these gold stars and they're posting
their life all day long like you get
paid from Snapchat yeah the vlogging but
like if I'm I'm seeing Dwayne The Rock
Johnson on snpp and I'm I'm able to see
all the behind the scene in his life and
then you know I'm having this talk with
the Snapchat reps and stuff and they're
like you get a whole different fan base
on a Snapchat side 100% I didn't know
that I'm I'm a big Tik Tok Instagram guy
so where you with YouTube shorts I am
I'm I'm my mans always tell me you got
to post on YouTube shorts I didn't know
how big of a thing that was like I'm
getting into it you you need to do
everything that's what I'm trying to get
into this is the point what the book
before we went live when you talk about
jab jab right hook the book I wrote that
was like here are the platforms that
matter here's the content that's working
so I have don't overthink it I have a
new book coming out called day trading
attention and I mean someone like you I
mean you by the way you know where your
[__] would go crazy where Facebook yep I
know you're the fourth person I didn't
told me that my [__] goes crazy on
Facebook I'm like some old Geer of
course your [__] goes crazy you're
[__] heartrob to those 80-year-old
[__] women on there oh my God like
this young boy is amazing his [__] I I
was checking out all your Instagram
people going crazy but that was fun yeah
bro the number one thing you need to do
out of this podcast is go home and
realize okay I've been bullshitting mhm
I need to do YouTube short proper I'm
I'm real proud of you cuz snap is the
one that everybody misses I've been
killing it snap is real [__] snap
YouTube shorts is incredibly YouTube
shorts is Tik Tok but but you won't get
as much reach up front but long term
because people search and then it leads
to your main channel That Is Like Oxygen
I got to go myself [__] and Facebook
Facebook what first of all couple things
that people don't realize the amount of
20 to 30 year olds that are on Facebook
still they're not going 18 hours a day
like you're they're on Tik Tok but
they're going but nobody contemporary is
making [__] for it so they're just it's
the same [__] as snap all this is is day
trading attention where's there more
attention than people that are good
making content there's the arbitr the
reason I went crazy about Tik Tok 5
years ago was I was on it when it was
musically and I was just waiting and
waiting and then there was a Tipping
Point two years before covid where I was
like oh [__] it's there and so I got
loud cuz I was winning but I wanted
other people to win and so that's what's
always going on I mean you've that is
imperative and then and then finally
live streaming twitch yeah twitch twitch
and even better than twitch actually cuz
twitch is hard like I only have 500
people watching right now you have to
build up over time I've got to earn it
it's going to be a grind Tik Tock live
Tik Tock live puts you into [__]
people's feeds while you're on so on
Instagram you go on it pings all your
users and a certain percentage comes
over and then it declines
so you know depending on your audience
side for me it's like 2,000 come on
right away and then 5 minutes later from
Yapp and I look up in the corner it's
800 it declines cuz my crew gets pinged
they check it out they're like I don't
give a [__] with Gary's doing the route
Tik Tok you go on it pings and you're
that's right and so you start you look
over there's 600 and then you look an
hour later you weren't even doing
anything proper and there's 4,000 people
there cuz they keep so and here's the
big thing I'm saying you3 and obviously
I'm saying it for everyone at home home
who's watching live now and who's
watching listening on the podcast in the
next weeks or a year from now the key is
to day trade attention when something's
there you got to squeeze it cuz it's not
always there all those [__] didn't
jump to Tik Tok when I was saying it cuz
they had a nice little gig on Instagram
and they were nice and cozy getting
their thousand likes there and they felt
good about their self-esteem because on
Tik Tok they had no followers the
problem was once the attention moved all
winning on Instagram now is hard mhm
supply and demand the end heard yes you
right now in this hot moment are you
[__] kidding me YouTube Shorts
Facebook like chat chat says something
new Instagram reals yeah reals are great
but it's listen this is what I do for a
living I'm not even going by my content
this company spends billions of dollars
in advertising and makes millions of
pieces of ads a year like I can see the
whole for it's not I'm in it and I'm
that guy I'm proud of how good I am at
it but I have much more data than
everybody yeah like this is like
Instagram's great it's harder mhm if you
do the same effort on Instagram that you
would do on Facebook snap YouTube shorts
or Tik Tok you will get more on all four
of those than Instagram Instagram is the
established Social Network right now
yeah not like unbelievable amounts of
content put on on Instagram with with a
heavy percentage every minute that
somebody spends on Tik Tok today was an
Instagram minute five five years ago
Fair G do you think that's why like it
seems like Instagram is more valuable if
you have a large you can have if if you
have a like I'll put it this way I know
people who are have million a million
followers on Tik Tok and aren't really
monetized if you have a million
followers on Instagram you're you you're
you're caked different B when you say
monetize ads from the platform I just
mean they're not getting a lot of brand
deals yeah they're not getting and so
like how that's because that's because
the decision maker in corporations yeah
are behind the times yeah so not a
million followers isn't as valuable to
Brands as 500,000 Instagram follow for
another 24 months and then it will flip
yeah the problem is go get a million
followers on Instagram yeah no way it's
hard it's very hard it's very hard TK to
you get one in a month I did it in a
month I'm at 500k 550 I think he could
decide he wants to and if he did and
then took his then you're trading your
own attention if he wanted to get 2
million he could yeah he would just
decide for next weeks to go ham on Tik
Tok and push everyone to Instagram maybe
do a contest Everybody follow me there
I'm going to pick three of you and have
dinner tonight in the city guess what
that 550 would be 7:30 tonight M but he
might not want to because followers
aren't the same anymore the social media
I grew up with was email marketing yeah
you would get a million followers and
then 35% of the certain percentage of
them would see it now there's people I
got 15 million followers on Tik Tok
there's people on their first post
getting more views on that video than me
cu the content is the variable not how
many followers you have all of us
stopped following people because the
algorithm sends it to us so they're like
oh I like this car B stuff but like
they're like I'll see it again you don't
think the way we did six years ago you
follow this is a real [__] game it's
about how many likes you have on your on
your Tik to
page changes watch shares right now on
Instagram it shares this is what I like
this is what I spent all like shares is
the call to action there so it just and
by the way and in three wants Instagram
might want something else to be the
thing and Tik Tok this so there this is
real [__] [__] yeah all right going
back around the other way as a kid who
let's give some flowers who was your
idol as a kid or who was if you can
think of one person that you just
thought was the [__] greatest I'll go
first don
madingley don madingley from the New
York Yankees first baseman the Yankees
sucked in my era the 80s the Yankees
were bad Donnie baseball Donnie baseball
going to be with them on Sunday I love
him please send them my love you
should be dialing you should I dial you
up when I'm with them are you supposed
to do a card I don't think you did a
card oh you're right thank you thank you
brother yeah of course keep your round
come come back protective Panther I'll
tell you why I've had a great first
month of the year my sister and I are
communicating via text and calls at
FaceTime so much in the first month
compared to like even last seven years
follow we always chop it up and we're
very very close but I feel like we're
like it's really nice like I would say
we're very close but I think like
this month has been remarkable like
we're just locked in you know when you
know how it is right with e
relationships um so I'm feeling great
about it but it was funny when I looked
at the cards it tapped into a feeling I
was so protective of my sister growing
up cuz I was an 80s kid and you went
outside yeah and I was going outside
when I was eight she was five and we
were outside and Mom don't get mad but
my mom didn't know where the [__] we
were it was the 80s nobody knew the [__]
parents are all freaked out on this when
I was 9 years old my mom had no [__]
clue where I was and I was outside yeah
somewhere also was outside was outside
out bro and by the way outside when I
was n in 1984 meant we were on the
railroad tracks on some standby me [__]
some dangerous we were [__] hitting
we used to have a game called we would
have a game called sticks where any one
of us this 10 kids this our crew we'd be
like sticks you know what it meant you
need to pick up a stick and hit each
other
this is what happens when there's no
phones there just fine [__] to
get running across the street [__]
cars whizzing by on some like like we
were like little kid Frogger like it was
like it was so anyway because of that
though your instincts I was protecting
my sister constantly I thought I was
grown at 11 and she was eight I got to
take care of her and so protective
Panther hit me in this pack of like I
loved being protective I learned how to
be a leader because of my sister I was
built for who I ended up becoming cuz I
got the training in the trenches for my
sister and now you
reconnected I want I want to pain a very
clear pict con we I just feel like for
the first time in a long time we have a
great connection I have an amazing
relationship with my sister consistently
it feels like it leveled up for some
reason and it's so fun for me like it
feels so warm and homey and amazing and
delicious and the best i' like feel like
5 years ago or something or maybe 3
years ago you were like follow if I ever
gave you a value follow her and I shot
her follow so I I see all her real
estate if you want to buy a house in
Jersey hit
up all right your turn mine Jim Carrey
okay I love Jim Carrey as a kid I still
do to this day I just feel like he was
so himself that's one of the people I
idolize like when it comes to telling my
fans and telling people who know me I
like being myself I like by I apologize
brother Kade 9671 says I don't [__] with
Gen X I just want to talk about this for
a half a second if I may got
you the world is very bad at something
it's called we have found more and more
ways to not like each other facts agree
right we religion is well documented
it's been a problem for 10,000 years
race well documented gender
unfortunately boys versus girls it es
and flows but not well documented we
have done such a good job and that's me
saying we've done a bad job we have
allowed 8 billion humans on Earth to
continuously find things on gender race
income level country I'm American I
Italy hate SP country and the fact that
we have now crossed over into another
one which is called generational hate
the fact that Boomers hate j z and gen Z
hates Gen X and and the fact that a
human would type I don't [__] with Gen X
by the way I'm in Gen X we don't even
get talked about I'm just pumped to even
mention Gen X it's Millennials Boomers
gen Z I don't even know if people know
Gen X exist I didn't even know what Gen
X was honest yeah yeah the fact that
we're in this place where we are
continuously looking to find another
thing to hate each other about drives me
[__] crazy ridic yeah that's corny
it's stupid the whole thing [__]
sucks anyway go ahead yeah no sorry Jim
Carrey um he just saw himself and I used
to try to still to this day I try to
find ways to look up J car interviews
because I just want to see I just want
to see him talk I want to see the things
like how did he grow up how was his
relationship with his family like he's
just from Ace ventor my favorite movie
is the MK from the Grinch like I just
love Jim Carrey and it was always
awkward to my mom she was like Jim
Carrey like you love Jim Carrey like
that and even now I got on interviews
and they say who's someone you love I
love Jim car Jim the man well abah
Lincoln I was I was I was I was really
lost you I have a dad and all that stuff
and I go to this summer camp to work and
I was a dishwasher and I went to this
guy Alie Jackson he's a big black man
very large and I said to him you know
you know I hear you have a this training
program you think I could train he goes
and he's you know white boy you can
sharpen my knives and we'll see how that
goes so every morning I go I'm there
crack a dawn I'm sharpening the guy's
knives at some point after about two
weeks he's like stay away from my knives
there be no knives left no there be no
knives left cuz I was just chopping them
all day and he took me under his wing
and actually taught me how to cook and
um you know he was just incredible like
a dad to me just taught me everything
told me the truth I'm like the opposite
about whatever that person was talking
about with Jen Z like this guy took me
under his wing told told me the truth
told me all the things I needed to know
and learn about how old were you started
about 16 amazing and this guy you know
besides teaching me how to cook soups he
just worked for Campbell he was a hat
maker but this guy I'll just tell you a
quick story this guy we're making
Chinese food one day me and uh this
guy's satch everybody had a nickname
growing up so we're cooking this canes
food fried rice our balls are on fire
the ovens are right underneath and we
get in at 5:30 in the morning cooking so
this was an easy meal we cooked
everything in the morning afternoon we
take a few hours off come back for
dinner so we get off of work it's like
100° out we just killing ourselves go
get a beer we go back to the room we
have like an hour left we have to go
back and we take a little nap s comes
running in my room go wake up wake up
like there was a fire he goes we miss
dinner it's 10: to 7: you know the help
at at 5:15 the camp at at 6:00 we go in
the kitchen and we start yelling and
screaming pots are throwing I'm going
around the kitchen saying you let us
sleep through the meal you're future in
this kitchen is uncertain I mean you may
not make it I don't even know if you're
going to make the summer and he's like
my my my buddy satch is like you black
you you man you're the so at some point
he the Al he had enough he calls us St
to get get us out of the kitchen because
we're creating a Ruckus pots are flying
and we're like dead
serious
and satch is physically getting removed
from the kitchen with two people he
won't leave because we let we the guys
let us sleep through so on the way out
I'm near the door and I go
Alie why don't you wake us and he just
gives me this green he goes I just
thought I'd give you the night
off and I think about it's like we're s
17 years old working aund and some hours
a week and we're pissed off because he
gave us the night off and that's the
kind of Pride like that's what he
instilled people say where do you get
your work ethic from like I'm like you
know that's a beautiful unbelievable
right you don't know I I believe that
people are placed in your life trying to
guide you to run it to him and then and
I never would gone to college it wasn't
for him it's amazing never no way he's
like you got to go to college and
explain how to do it how it all worked
so you know you you're very very
fortunate I love that shout out to him
yeah I think I've had like different
Heroes at different stages of life like
different things I've been doing
obviously I had great parents growing up
so it's awesome and great um friends you
know friends parents that were really
really pivotable in my pivotal in my
life too
um professionally I really really looked
up to Jay Wright as a coach I love J J
Jay Wright was the coach of Villanova
yeah he won two national championships
as a Knicks fan we're basically
Villanova we're vova I'm a Knicks guy
too so go uh Jaylen Brunson went to my
high well I should say I went to his
high school now he was after me though
but um yeah so professionally him uh now
like comedy wise I'm big Adam Sandler
fan I feel like the world just needs
movie that's just like a Feelgood you
know he's going to win the golf
championship at the end to just give us
Happy Gilmore like why is everything so
complicated nowadays um so yeah because
in life we find what we look for yeah
and we've just decided to start looking
for the negative meanwhile the world is
unlimited positive yeah it's everywhere
around you the problem is humans see
what they're looking for yeah it's just
the biggest truth yep I this is
something I'm so passionate about
brother yeah if if you decide to look
for positivity there's unlimited
positivity everywhere facts Good Vibes
everywhere I think even like even in
comments like you and I experien it and
Gary you too and I'm sure you being on
the Internet it's like you'll get hate
comments of course like I mean I can't I
didn't even know I had a weird neck
until I got on the internet I was like
oh I guess I have a weird neck and weird
looks like I think I have a long neck I
think it's just looks athletic good I
like your neck I mean I've been putting
on some weight you know what I mean you
look that's good looks like take a shot
to the face thanks man I wish I had that
neck I think it's more just kind of like
the mouth melts into the you know
there's not I wish I could do like yeah
that seems like you could do something
CRA than guys appreciate it I B every
video just get I basically just do this
and breathe in my videos that's like J
right was random though see that coming
I I think I just was awesome I I'll I'll
give a quick story really quick story I
went to go see a practice when I was
coaching at York I was able to get in
see a practice right he was coaching
yeah I was Co coaching basketball and I
he was able to hold a kid accountable a
really a fstar recruit he was able to
hold this kid accountable without
screaming and I was like a young coach
and I was like I was a screamer I was
like oh you know tough kids I was in
Brooklyn wasy you know Dey were walking
through metal detector so I was like I'm
not the [__]
one I think I'm Coach Carter or whatever
it is and you realize that like you
don't need I I just Le such a value I'm
I apologize do you know the only time I
was ever universally booed on stage cuz
I've had a very good public speaking
career was at the height of his
popularity at South by Southwest I said
[__] Steve Jobs I never want to be like
him and people were crazy really and and
I said let me explain myself I'm like
all of you in Silicon Valley now are
being mean to employees because the
stories are out that he's tough and not
nice and all of you are trying to be not
nice yeah and and I was trying to set
the tone for who I am now yeah even back
then of like I believe who you are as a
person how people talk about you behind
your back important is way important
it's the only thing don't give a [__]
how much money you made [__] you who
gives a [__] do many rich people die and
three people show up to their funeral
you think that's a good life the [__]
the matter with people right the [__]
are we spitting hate for you hating
someone when people leave negative
comments on my account I feel bad for
them yeah I don't feel father living
life going around trying to make other
people feel bad and their father this
shit's not
funny I 3 minutes later ready I got to
get the [__] out of here I want to tell
one quick thing one quick thing ask
permission if you before you kill
somebody to let them know what your
intent is that you're going to you know
you want them to be great and not it's
not personal so if I kill you it's just
to make you better and have that in a
really normal conversation it's unbel
how many employees now say it's okay you
can get crazy with me but I'm asking
your permission to do it so this way
when I'm doing it and honestly I'm in J
school like to me you guys know this
Dustin we've been together how long 5
and a half years you've filmed me
constantly how many times have you seen
me yell at
someone why
you what and I get it we've all got my
father yelled at like at everyone yeah I
get it I'm just and by the way that's
beautiful like hey but like it it has no
positive effect yeah like that's your
unhappy yeah that's your own weakness
that's you reflecting anyway I love you
all thank you for being on the show
awesome much thanks girls bye everybody
love
[Music]
you